thought thoughts I've been having
recently are like you know what drive so
much which which pretty much drives
almost everything in the world i think
is is like you know we look at the world
and we see things that that don't exist
we see these voids and it's just like
and at some point or another it's either
someone someone sees it and says you
know that this should be here and it's
not here you know and and so you know
it's either you to take it on and create
it or someone else comes along it's what
it feels that what he creates it so what
is it about shoots you know where you're
sort of seeing something that doesn't
already exist and and you want to kind
of take this on and put it out into the
world well I think one aspect is um it
is our cast um it's the fact that we
have Latino leads on in non
stereotypical roles it's just you know
it's roles that could be played by you
know anyone they just so happened to be
Latino which is which is nice to have a
diverse cast on you know all across the
board Oh Vikram one of the other main
characters um is a play by karthik um
and even don't you the web series it was
that it was that way to where you know
the two factors that we had cast and
harrison as parents both of them you
know had said thank you is there like it
was the first time I get to play a
scientist is the first time I get to
play that you know they both had had
accents mu she wasn't playing you know
hot latina it was just like that kind of
that kind of thing I think was very much
appreciated where they got to do
something that was that was different
and we kind of took that on into the to
the new project into the future as well
wanting to to give them interesting
roles and and that aren't the stereotype
um yeah so i think it's it's finding
roles that people don't necessarily
always get to play but doesn't look out
a place either it's not like oh I don't
believe that person as that it's just
you know this is what you're seeing more
day to day in real
is these different types of things you
know we have Amanda cast as you know
this brilliant person from the future um
who's you know kind of more serious um
you know she's a blonde and you know
blonde sometimes get typecast as well
into circles if she was gonna have to
dye her hair really know you could be a
blunt yeah she has to become the serious
brunette but that's not the case at all
you know we're trying to you know keep
it keep it different so I think one
aspect that's important to us about
about shoots is that cast aspect the
other thing is just you know it's a cool
concept because again it goes back to
the lo-fi sci-fi and what we're looking
at isn't you know a period piece going
back to the 50s but um you know going
back you know if you could go back two
years ago you know what does that mean
like what what if you could change that
and um you know it's just it's looking
at those ideas of um you know how much
how much how much control do we have
like man that it's it's okay because it
happened for a reason but then um you
know I should why should I keep trying
if everything happens for a reason it if
I knew that finding that balance in you
know people who go through these tough
situations how do they find that peace
and at the same time keep having that
drive and that's that's really what the
story's about and what what these
characters are going through and I think
that's what that's the part that
interests me most about the story why I
really wanted her to tell it is those
ideas
you